bonjour je me présente madame sigismeau
béatrice g 63 ans
je suis
adjointe au maire de saint-pierre et 4e
vice présidente au département pour un
troisième mandat les électeurs du canton
21,5 hier deux m'ont sollicité et m'ont
mis en place pour ce troisième mandat
je suis élu sur le canton 21 saint
pierre 2 et j'habite dans le canton
les actions prioritaires que se veut
porter pour mon canton pour saint-pierre
et pour la réunion c'est bien entendu le
projet de solidarité territoriale
qui prend en compte les besoins des
communes principalement l'action sociale
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
l'accompagnement aussi aux populations
qui sont en souffrance et le aussi gérer
les problèmes de l'habitat et de la
jeunesse je m'attacherai aussi
apporter la culture et le sport comme
pilier de l'insertion
professionnelle parce que c'est
important aujourd'hui d'accompagner nos
jeunes vers un projet de vie un projet
professionnel et qui trouve vraiment
leur place dans la société
alors améliorer la qualité de vie des
réunionnais à l'avenir c'est aussi
prendre en compte
la transition écologique que nous vivons
aujourd'hui est que nous devons mettre
en oeuvre en adéquation bien sûr avec
notre population la population doit être
concertée doit travailler avec nous sur
ce sujet on a déjà commencé à le faire
mais sur cette nouvelle mandature ça va
être un point important est le
département s'est engagé déjà sur la
tentation d'un million d'arbres mais que
ce tir et c'est un sujet très vaste où
on aborde aussi l'économie circulaire le
développement durable et c'est un sujet
qui intéresse l'ensemble des réunionnais
et je m'engage vraiment à travailler sur
ce point